we've looked at mathematics and driving
firstly all kinds of costs you need to
get a car right
but those aren't only the costs involved
we want to keep the car and we want it
to be useful to us okay
now
there are two kinds of costs you really
need to worry about the first one we
actually already know a whole bunch of
these these are the costs that are going
to be the same no matter how much you
use the car or not that's why they call
standing costs as if the car is just
standing there there's still all this
money you have to spend on it and
they're ongoing they're ongoing so for
instance i think someone already
mentioned registration right
registration we already know about this
how often do you have to pay for
registration
every bar depends on
every year
every year every year um your license
lasts a bit longer than that but the
registration for the car does not okay
and that's because cars go through wear
and tear and you might recall
registration one of the big things about
it is making sure the car is still
roadworthy and stuff like that so it's
every 12 months has to be checked
otherwise it's illegal
between yeah it depends on the kind of
car we looked at this right the kind of
car what you're using for etc okay
can someone tell me another ongoing cost
that you have to pay regardless of how
much or how little you drive the car
insurance okay we looked at that so we
talked about the different kinds like
ctp and comprehensive right
registration we got insurance
now these two things they're fairly
obvious money going out but most
recently or was it the very last lesson
i think it was the very last lesson that
we did there was kind of this invisible
cost because your car gets older and it
gets damaged and so it loses value and
we call that depreciation very good
okay depreciation um now there's one
more that you already know about
actually you might have dealt with it in
maybe your first lesson in mathematics
and driving assuming perhaps you don't
actually have like 30 grand just sitting
in your bank but you still want to buy a
car so you go to them you make a deal
right you get a loan
so that's going to cost you money right
what do we call that yeah loan interest
right
and you've got to pay that
consistently maybe every couple of weeks
maybe every month all that kind of thing
now all of these things are the same
even if your car is just sitting or
standing in your garage and not driving
it at all yeah can you buy a car with
like lay-by
can you buy a car with labor
can be lay by a car so hold on soon lay
by how what what is lay-by
the way you can
have it but you like paid off after
so that's what this is so most cars most
people buy cars on finance is the way we
would say it in this context um and yeah
it's exactly the same it's just like a
mortgage
but for a car
now there's one extra cost which i
haven't included here we haven't really
talked about uh which is still a
standing cost it's still something you
have to pay ongoing regardless of how
much or how little you drive
has anyone ever been broken down on the
road like actually their car they've
hammered yeah okay and so what do you
get when you're broken down on the road
you get roadside assist right now the
biggest company that does that unless
it's in rma right
but there's um
there's lots of other companies that
will do it
and this is something you really do want
to pay for what if there's no signal
if there's no signal
then you are in trouble
um then i think you've got bigger
problems then yeah that's right that's
why then you don't know when some
strangers
okay now
out of these five costs out of these
five costs
um
three of them have to do with actually
having your car on the road um
registration if you want your car on the
road you've got to pay that um insurance
and roadside assist right
on the road
uh well you can i'll talk about that in
a second right
all of these these three that i've just
highlighted they're called on-road costs
in fact that's kind of an important
phrase
so you might want to write that down
on-road costs
now these on-road costs are separate to
depreciation and loan interest they have
nothing to do with your car being on the
road does that make sense
these things are not going to change
they're just dependent on well how how
much is the cars value changing over
time what kind of loan did you get in
the first place
but regardless all these things are the
same they're consistent drive lots drive
a little
they don't know
okay so therefore standing costs they
are in opposition to
things that increase as you drive more
and more and more we call these
operating costs because when you're
operating car
you have to pay more for them
operating costs um
what kinds of things can you think of
the more you use the car the more you're
going to pay
petrol that's the obvious one
tired okay good the the more you use
your car the more things you're going to
wear and tear and the main thing is the
tires right so there's tires
when people go and get um what is it
yeah so servicing good so
you're the car manufacturer will
recommend that you have to um
service it every however often maybe
three months six months et cetera
i should point out you don't have to do
that there's no there's no law unlike
here that requires you to go in and pay
money but if you don't do this what's
gonna probably happen to your car
yeah it's gonna break down stop you know
it's gonna start like making funny
noises out of it and then before you
know the smoke coming out of the bonnet
yeah that's right that's right so you
can sometimes they'll do it by time as
you know only half of six months 12
months sometimes they'll do it by
kilometers generally whichever comes
first that makes sense okay
there's three can anyone think of any
others
washing it yeah i suppose so but i don't
think they affect you as much as these
because your car can keep on driving
even when it's gross right and when
people are riding on the back clean me
you know it still drives just fine what
if it's like money on the front
yeah okay but your car can it's got you
know windscreen wipers and we'll still
function yeah
say it
yeah okay so i guess what you can say is
tires tires are really um
an emblem of all the consumables in your
car okay so you could put a whole bunch
of things under there like the battery
like the um i don't know like the gas
that makes the air conditioner actually
function those kinds of things um and of
course if your car actually does break
down because of wear and tear you've got
to repair it um you'll know i haven't
actually written battery there because
batteries are a funny thing
usually the more you drive your car
the longer the battery lasts does anyone
know why
yeah camera goes it charges itself when
you drive particularly when you drive
over long distances not stop starting
that kind of thing you're actually
charging the battery as you go so if you
let a car sit there for like six months
and then don't drive it there's a good
chance it won't start again because the
battery's gone dead in that time